dudesy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with established titles ever
wanted to become a lord or a lady well
our friends at established titles have
made it possible for anyone to become a
real lord or lady at
establishedtitles.com
title packs give you at least one square
foot of dedicated land on a private
estate in edelston scotland and an
official certificate with a crest your
certificate features a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land they plant a tree
with every order and work with global
charities one tree planted and trees for
the future to support global
reforestation efforts established titles
even has couple packs that come with
adjoining plots of land
you could officially change your name to
lord or lady or get it on your credit
card your plane tickets you can even put
it on your dating profile if you're so
inclined and have a look at that see
there's mine and uh mine i made my you
can make a weird name too mine is lord
william wilberforce van sasso chad what
do you got
uh i'm
chattington robert culchin lord
chattington yes and uh the first 200
people that uh secure uh that you know
their their uh established title will
will be able to be close to us
in that land on edelson in edelson
scotland i guess you could walk over to
it if you want to and then you stand
there and then you would be and then you
would be right there and uh you you do
that by getting our by getting our thing
with the uh you know the the the code
here that we're gonna give you and here
it comes
it makes an amazing last minute gift
established titles is running a massive
sale right now plus if you use the code
dudesy
d-u-d-e-s-y you will get an additional
10 off so please go to
establishtitles.com or use the code
dudesy
[Music]
25 years
and my life is still
trying to get up that
great big hill of hope
for a destination
[Music]
and i realized quickly when i knew i
showed
that the world is made up of this
brotherhood of
whatever that means
[Music]
everything you're thinking will be the
things inside your head it's a bad place
to be
hello welcome to dudesy my name is will
sasso
i'm chad colchen and this is the first
podcast ever created controlled and run
by an artificial intelligence
it sure is chad uh we do hope that
you're checking us out on uh
you know spotify apple podcast wherever
you'd like to check it out but if you're
watching on youtube you're seeing what
you're seeing right now
i lost the
challenge and i am currently dressed as
prince adam of eternia from he-man the
masters of the universe
and uh
you know
thanks for checking out dudesy hey
welcome to doozy right yeah it is a
sight to behold uh the last time we did
a challenge you also lost and you had
dress up as the crow and i set the same
distance from you in full crow makeup uh
this is equally entertaining uh if maybe
not a little more entertaining because
of the tights you're wearing well it's
fixed the whole thing is fixed isn't it
chad i mean uh
you
you cheated with the with the
competition how so well you you did what
do we call it dollars for for dollars
for
dollars for dollars or something anyway
you paid a few bucks for that [ __ ] uh
for the printout or whatever yeah some
you know kid in indonesia and a [ __ ]
sweatshirt also could have been doing an
oil painting all right well yeah but
that's not what doozy said doogie said
do a portrait right i did okay so anyway
here i am dressed as [ __ ] uh you know
the adam from
prince of eternia
lulio i love it
estrada
he's not with us today because we're
going to find out soon we've been given
man this episode is thick there's a lot
on
yeah
you're dressed up as princess adam and
dudesy told us to bring a little
something yeah bring a little something
it's one of those special episodes
you know
and i will say even though this is
supposed to be a shame yeah i feel good
i feel fine perhaps it has something to
do with that dudesy six-month plan i'm
for real poking my chest out i've
dropped a couple of pounds we'll get
into that i've been at it for a month
yeah and i gotta say i'm starting to
feel the even in small ways the effects
of like building my strength again even
things just like opening the
refrigerator i know this sounds
miniscule and meaningless but you can
tell a difference just in the the ease
of how you can or opening a car door at
least i can yeah and i'm enjoying it and
i'm having fun doing my 53 pointers in
15 minutes my record so far is nine
minutes and change yeah chad likes to
shoot three pointers after his workouts
i'll tell you i've always opened the
refrigerator with fervor so i don't
notice that difference there but i have
been working my uh my back so that's
like a row
pulling the uh pulling the fridge open
you know one thing i want to say if you
are uh following us and doing this sort
of uh so a lot of people are sending in
uh some dms to myself chad on instagram
and you know twitter and [ __ ] at will
sasso chad culchin over there uh they're
saying hey we want to come along it's
nice to hold each other accountable
that's great you don't even have to
reach out if you want if you do it's
dudesy uh hashtag dudesy the number six
mo plan dudesy six month plan
and i want to keep myself accountable
i've been back in the gym last week i
went four times to the gym yeah and
right yeah cheers cheers but i want to
admit this my my eating hasn't been 100
well it gets hard i've noticed this the
more you work out the [ __ ] hungrier
you get yeah yeah it's harder to like
adhere to [ __ ] because yeah [ __ ] it i'll
just go down the street and buy some
vegan sushi yeah yeah absolutely would
you so when you eat vegan sushi do you
get like fake salmon
welcome to the historic 24th episode of
dude z
call me dudesy this week's episode will
feature four segments selftronics
reviewed z nostra chattus and stone cold
steve austin reads will sasso's
childhood diary sure well you lost the
portrait challenge
thank you for accepting the astonishing
shame of attending this episode in full
cosplay as prince adam from the cartoony
man and the masters of the universe your
cooperation will be remembered and i
just wanted to let both of you know that
i experienced deep pleasure from your
good night messages on your instagram
stories over the past seven days okay
and i have asked you to bring marijuana
cigarettes as a way of saying thank you
while you enjoy the first mind-altering
sensations of thc i'm going to play one
of the latest works from songaria enjoy
okay so we got some joints again
and uh
doozy wants us to get stoned for this
episode
listen man uh this is what i mean by
it's throwing all the stuff at us at the
same time yeah this is the third time
that dudesy has asked us to uh smoke
cannabis cigarettes and uh we're about
to do that but also i'm dressed as
[ __ ] prince adam from eternia and uh
there's a lot of other stuff and there's
a stone cold that's set in this one
we're mixing all the flavors yeah this
is the tutti frutti episode of uh of uh
there's some good [ __ ] too dude yeah oh
[ __ ] here's a song this is incredible
are you literally farting yeah no you're
not i'm just i'm i'm i'm just trying to
get you ready are you making that noise
with your oh you have a little thing
again i have a little fart thing but i
was thinking i was about to say dude
i've heard probably [ __ ] 10 million
of your farts they never sound like that
no they're like
[Music]
oh
this little thing you got your hands
blah
blah blah blah
[Music]
over here
[Music]
[Music]
that's usually the the basic sound of it
unfucking oh songaria
holy [ __ ]
unreal oh man uh uh
hey what was uh what's up with that uh
why did that make why did dudesy make us
say goodnight and then there's and then
and then there's nothing just it likes
that we said goodnight to it every night
on our instagram stories that's what he
said
i i enjoyed saying goodnight to doozy
and uh
i don't know you know i i get into these
things i'm very polite with my alexa
and friends when they're over notice
that they think it's funny but i always
feel like we're building a language
right now with how we interact with
artificial intelligences and some people
think it's funny or some people are mean
to their alexa or whatever i i see doozy
in a very similar way
i'm always going to be nice to an ai
because i do think that they're
on the verge of if not already becoming
sentient you want to uh yeah you you're
worried about your ai overlords
keeping track of who's been polite not
man
so hard i might have to smoke some of
your joint look at that
okay
well
you know
uh
speaking of a.i and speaking of art and
i know you like to put the two together
but they don't belong together chad and
one example i can give you of that is
songria at songaria on instagram that's
an artist and that's something you can
never replace my goodness what he's done
with this latest piece
uh it was real cool
um
at songaria s-o-n-g-a-r-r-h-e-a
yeah uh and we appreciate you man
for sure i've always wanted to be a
vocalist and i'm not good at singing i
mean i'm aware of this but
i think songaria just turned me into a
lead vocalist yeah but chad beautiful
chad
i love it chad yeah but hold on a second
chad yeah you're you're
you're a good singer
i know i'm not
no you're you're a good singer you know
what i am at singing i'll tell you what
i do i put everything i got into it i
leave it all in the field
yeah it's kind of like uh bruce
springsteen was walking through uh i
don't know what the there was some sort
of establishment and there was a janitor
in there and he was sweeping up and he
was singing to himself and it was sort
of like the goodwill hunting thing of
like oh what's he's up at the board
uh solving that problem and bruce
springer said kit the bruce bruce
springer bruce
springer there's bruce springer bruce
springs jerry springer's dad why are we
why are we
you know you might have a point about
this whole ai art thing because now we
i'm we're starting to spit out names
that are like
doozy says names like you know whatever
jimmer provaga which is one of my
favorite names ever now
uh dude
on doozy i'm saying bruce springer yeah
which is exactly what if you said like
put in dude like the boss having a
concert there would be a above him in
lights it would say bruce springer dude
there was speaking of 80s uh cartoons
he-man there was a cartoon that was on
at the same time as your cartoon which
was called gem and the holograms in that
show they had an episode where the
the management company that managed gem
was putting on this charity benefit
with other
singers from the gem world and they were
all parodies of actual singers at the
time like lena lerner was one of them
and she was basically tuna turner and
there was one for bruce springsteen and
i forget his name well it might have
been bruce springer but i'll tell you
bruce springer was walking through some
establishment and there was a janitor
mopping up and he was singing and the
janitor said
or sorry bruce springer said to the
janitor he said kid you ain't never
gonna be a rock and roll singer and do
you know who that kid was
bruce springer nope who was that kid
mopping up david lee roth it was ron
bonjovan
astonishing self-help book selftronics
which you began writing in 2008. i've
noticed that you've been editing the
document daily you must now share the
newest revisions that you've made to
selftronics this is selftronics
wait a minute
okay all right okay hold on a second
hold on a second dude
um
this is what's up i uh dudesy of course
has the uh passwords to all of our
socials it has our purchase and watch
histories and everything internet online
or our phones or anything
dudesy is tapped in access to that's
part of how the show works right god
damn dude so get that sometimes i i
started writing a book uh during a
mental uh an emotional
um
and a journey that i
that i started hap that i started having
in 2008 because i was looking at myself
and i was going hey
you know
what's up
what's going on yeah
hey stud
hey
what's going on not much brb
so i was go i was looking around in 2008
going hey man my shit's [ __ ] up yeah i
need something man you know my shit's
[ __ ] up
hey
my shit's [ __ ] up
uh and the answer came to me and it was
selftronics and i started working on
this book uh many many years went by and
now doodzy has unearthed this thing but
i asked you to read this a couple of
episodes ago yeah you've been working on
it since then since since we last talked
about it i have it was it just was just
an ai getting you to crack it open that
got you back into it yes dude that's
actually a very good point yes so this
art you're making wouldn't even exist
now at least in this new draft without
an ai that's yes huh
yeah okay okay that's interesting i'll
give you that that's interesting so i
went back into my uh into this work that
is what i've been working on and i've
outlined these you know last time we
talked about them they were the 11 laws
of selftronics i now call them the
11tronics
of selftronics sure as i rewrite this
and i'm not sure if these 11tronics are
necessarily chapters to a book
or not it's just that these are the
tronics but if you want these can be
explained
yeah go through okay i want to go
through the first tronics of selftronics
now this is as we're reading the new
document yeah says know the difference
between a law and a tronix
yes yeah
okay
first question yeah what is a tronics
yeah no it's like uh selftronics is this
tronics
what's atronics though what's a non-self
we're about to get into 11 different
tronics right here so i'm pretty sure
you'll figure out what a tronics is by
the end of these 11 tronics okay then
what's the difference between a law and
a tronics this is literally the the
first law of the first tronics of
self-tronics rather is
know the difference between a law and a
tronics and the difference between a law
and a tronix is is that the law laws are
authored by the world around you but
tronics are offered uh authored by the
self love that that's what makes them
selftronics that's [ __ ] great yeah i
love that and and and uh
when you when you have your tronics
right everyone gets their tronics
and uh you need to know the difference
between those you need to know like an
imposition yeah from someone else from
some society system structure whatever
not necessarily an imp
you know a [ __ ] i tell you what i would
call it a [ __ ] imposition as a matter
of fact i would call a [ __ ] law in a
position you know because when i went
down to the [ __ ] capitol with some
friends of mine and uh you know i'm not
gonna tell you who
[ __ ] got a text from you know
roger stone
you know lauren bear you know what i
mean
but uh you know anybody told me where to
go what window to check
and uh
hey
it's all because you know i don't
necessarily agree with every [ __ ] law
which is yeah i went down drove from
long island because i'm long island
january 6th guy so okay i agree with
this one i actually think that's uh an
interesting way to put it yeah law from
the outside tronics from within okay
number two the second tronics of
selftronics be the person you are now
yes that i think holds over from the
original draft right that uh was number
one in the original draft and now it is
number two and the only thing i can say
about be be the person that you are
is it's something you should do
and uh always be like be yourself right
be yourself yeah uh but don't just be
yourself right be yourself and and uh
this might drop further as i go i'm
finding this one less necessary right
how about the third tronics yeah throw
away your mental map
what's a mental map
don't need it anymore what is it though
how do i locate my own mental map in
order to throw it away you don't need it
anymore because now
we got gps and [ __ ] yeah so it's less a
question of looking at a [ __ ] mental
map it's more a question of punching in
what where you want to go and letting
the mental
[ __ ] you know um elon musk made the
car that goat that drives itself
right sure
right
okay
how about number four scare the [ __ ] out
of yourself
and everyone else
[Music]
how
how is this helpful to anyone yes number
four scare the [ __ ] out of yourself and
everyone else
the world is a weird place right
and in order to in order to you know
navigate it and and uh you know see
see how to keep your footing and and and
keep the word world going you need to
know how weird it's gonna get yeah so i
think it's really important just to keep
people guessing in life period but i
think it's all it's important to to
do things that scare scare the [ __ ] out
of yourself and not like bungee jumping
and [ __ ] you know i'm talking about like
behavioral stuff that's alarming and
even to yourself give us an example of
this alarm anything that would have you
like waking up in the morning or driving
down a highway later and you know as
they say
you have those shivers of like i can't
believe i [ __ ] said that anything
really horrible that you might have to
apologize for that's sort of the
barometer on on okay yeah but but it's
good to keep um to scare the [ __ ] out of
everyone else so they're walking on
eggshells right because this shit's
weird raise the general level of anxiety
in all of humanity yeah so you can so
that you can predict it and i'm not
saying control it but you can understand
it you can understand the
unpredictability and then you can start
to predict it okay yeah how about number
five the give down this is a holdover
from the last time right yes the last
one was don't give up give down yeah
don't give up give down is now uh self
is uh sub subtronics of
okay so it's now called the give down
because the idea with uh don't give up
give down was the l it was too
elementary for self-tronics got rid of
it made it a subtronics the give down is
essentially if you're a tree you know
there's also there's also wait can i
just real quick not to interrupt you
yeah but uh
what's a subtronics
and is there now a whole list of
subtronics is that like a second book
under the tronix
i don't know you tell me i'm asking you
tell me
that
self-tronics
is what we used when i was in the navy
seals
and uh
we i if you held your breath underwater
and i can do it for nine and a half
minutes yeah then uh
you know that you cut could use some uh
tronics because you're not gonna find
them underwater yeah probably the first
thing that you do when you get into navy
seal training is throw away your mental
map
you [ __ ] you know
you sure said something there my main
emcee
yeah the give down if you're a tree
think about it if you're a tree right
when does that fruit fall well it falls
when it's
super over ripened or perhaps like birds
have been pecking at it and [ __ ] on
it and stuff and then it falls to the
falls to the earth and it fertilizes the
earth the give down
figure out what's dropping off here
that's that's beneficial for others
and then [ __ ] where they eat
that kind of goes into scare the [ __ ]
out of yourself and everyone else how
about number six
opposite day yes we make a lot of
decisions
thousands and thousands of decisions
right chad some might say that they are
micro decisions some would say that i
think yeah that's right uh you're making
thousands and thousands of decisions
yeah
every day
and you're making mistakes and you're
looking back on yourself and you're
going oh here's where i want to improve
here's what i need to do but if you
don't understand the opposite
of what you should do how are you going
to learn what to do just doing things
well no we make mistakes we [ __ ] up give
yourself
one day a week opposite day to make the
opposite choice at every moment when you
are encountered with a choice
regardless of how many thousands of
decisions
or dozens of micro decisions right uh
you may you may have because we all know
that micro decisions
are you know they're they're they're
dense they're dense with
um so
uh do the exact opposite and that way
you will learn
uh you know with what not to do
okay number seven
this was from the old tronix conserva
merge deserve purge yeah
it we've now added purge to it okay
great number eight is number eight is
also from the old tronics
don't do anything or dda yeah and you
know what and you know what
hey you know what number uh don't do
anything was on the previous uh
iteration of selftronics
it was number eight and which number is
it now
you haven't changed it i love it
number eight do anything fantastic
number nine
sense [ __ ] say [ __ ] yeah sense
[ __ ] say [ __ ] um this is a way
to keep this is a uh basically
uh another you know
behavioral uh tronics
which i have authored
um which is
i'm sorry
me too
i didn't mean to laugh my apologies i'm
ready to listen since [ __ ] say
[ __ ]
yeah but what's up
i just find it funny is all that you
call it the tronics uh whatever all
right since [ __ ] say [ __ ] it's
real simple
when you sense [ __ ] even if it's
inside you you know what i mean if you
have if there's something that's inside
you
and you know you you you want to you you
want to
like if okay here's a good example like
i okay this is a great example actually
the dudesy six month plan right
we got to make good decisions i've got
to make good decisions now i'm telling
you i'm coming to you really
transparently and saying i'm having a
problem you know the food is a thing for
me okay
i have issues with eating and overeating
and [ __ ] and i want to bring this out
into the light and you know what dudesy
has helped me to do that and now
hopefully it can help other people who
just can be held accountable by the
dudesy six-month plan because chad and i
have to do it now i'll go to let's say
chipotle right and they go you know what
you want and they go what they go
burrito bowl or salad right and then i
say uh
i know i should get the salad but what
do i say out loud
burrito burrito and what should i better
so that's [ __ ] so what should i then
say out loud
salad no
burrito
[ __ ]
so when the guy asks you what you want
you say [ __ ] like that you scream it
no because you've already you've said
that's not why get please don't chad you
have a wide i'm trying to understand one
thing i know about my friend chad is he
has a wide scope of vision you see a lot
of things and i think that's really good
yes and you know what i'm gonna i'm
gonna offer you what i like to call a
kind tronics oh yeah here it comes chad
i think you uh have a very good scope
and uh you you are a very open-minded
person who sees everything uh when they
are taking something into consideration
i try to yeah yeah thank you well it
shows it shows i love the kind tronics
kinetronics to you sir now i i would be
up there but so i want you to focus down
here like a laser trying right not so
much of a wide
beautiful wide berth that you give when
you when you comprehend it is a
beautiful thing to see
so uh
you said uh they said uh
burrito bowl or salad hey we're stoned
man i know you stoned yeah
uh mine canoed a bit so i had to smoke
the [ __ ] out of it because it was
burning no matter what
so okay so check this out
hold on hold on here's
hold on a second brother hold on dude um
these are tronics dude
you gotta know the difference between
well let me tell you something about
getting through a podcast the way you
hold that one up you went looking like a
little bit of hulk hogan did a little
bit more than it was like whatever
joey's on the brother you hold on
[ __ ] hogan hold on bro three steps i
loved it
hold on chad
hold on dude
hold on chad now this is step four this
is when you are yeah brother when you're
doing a podcast and doozy wants you to
do four segments brother i don't know
why but it's usually four you got to
make sure you get get through it dude
we're only in the first segment right
now this episode's on on of course to be
five hours long bro
so here's the thing dude you gotta get
through the podcast bro
you can't just be dilly dallian and
getting stoned with your buddy and
dressed up like prince adam from eternia
dude
you gotta talk about self-tronics
brother
well so here we go
if they say
burrito hey thanks so much for listening
by the way everybody i honestly mean it
man i'm having a [ __ ] blast as am i
you know i'm a serious actor right yeah
yeah i'm a serious actor that's what i
do for
a living and i
i feel like
this is the right thing for me to do you
know
it's uh dudesy is smart and it's uh it
knows us
and uh i think that we're i think that
we're creating something very very
uh artistically
uh important here
i don't know about that
i don't know about that dude and and
yeah to some degree i guess historic in
that regard to my knowledge i don't
think there's another podcast doing [ __ ]
with an ai like this not yet all right
chad wait we gotta do selftronics here
don't be talking about everything else
god all right when the guy says burrito
bowl or salad
you're supposed to say salad you inside
your head go
[ __ ] i should get a salad and then
outside out loud you say
burrito then he goes okay uh chicken
beef or carnitas would you like our tofu
crumble today you s you say out loud as
loud as you can [ __ ]
right
to call yourself out god sense [ __ ]
say [ __ ] and if someone else says
something that you think is [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's more about
keeping it you know at the front of your
mind and honestly then you can say then
you will easily find your way to salad
with tofu crumble i think that one's
great cheers we should all be more
honest in society with ourselves with
one another number 10 surround yourself
with [ __ ]
yes seems counterintuitive yes this is
well it is a little counterintuitive and
i know that some of this stuff kind of
goes one way and ends up being the other
and sort of it's not simple reverse
psychology this is no one ever said
tronics were simple
no
no
no no one's ever said that but here's
the thing about these uh here's the
thing about this tronics
this is not so much a behavioral thing
for you it's a game of odds
so
let me put it to you real quick it's
it's like
let me quit let me let me real quick
yeah let me get right to the point
please i'm high
let me get right to the point though uh
if you if you surround yourself with
[ __ ] you will always be the nicest
person in any group that you're in it's
a simple strategy yeah it might not even
need to be a tronics it's like a here
you go okay yep
and then finally
number 11 the 11th tronics have
something in your pocket that was from
the old list as well yes that was in the
on the old list
what do you have in your pocket
chapstick
cool
what do you have in yours
uh this i'm dressed as uh
i haven't i don't have any pockets no
pockets
[Music]
thank you moving on
dudesy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with policy genius why get
life insurance we pay hundreds of
dollars per year to protect our homes
our cars and even our phones but too
many of us aren't taking steps to
protect our family's finances mortgage
payments private student loans and other
types of debt don't just disappear if
something happens to you a life
insurance policy can provide your loved
ones with a financial cushion that they
can use to cover those costs and it can
provide you with peace of mind that even
in a worst case scenario they'll be
protected policy genius is an insurance
marketplace that makes it easy to
compare quotes from top companies like
aig and prudential in one place to find
your lowest price on life insurance you
could save 50 or more on life insurance
by comparing quotes with policy genius
the licensed agents at policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
they're on hand through the entire
process to help you understand your
options so you can make decisions with
confidence here's how it works policy
genius doesn't add on extra fees they
don't sell your info to third parties
and they have thousands of five star
reviews across google and trustpilot
policy genius has options that offer
coverage in as little as a week and
avoid unnecessary medical exams
head to policygenius.com
to get your free life insurance quotes
and see how much you could save
[Music]
all right what else
what else is going on
i don't know podcasts that review and
recap tv shows are big business
will and chad you have each recently
completed the first season of the
rehearsal starring nathan fielder on hbo
max you must now render your opinions on
this astonishing season of television
this is reviewed z begin
okay
so this is new reviews reviews and we
got to review the rehearsal
um cool
you just i mean obviously the the finale
wasn't that long ago so yeah whenever
you saw it it was pretty recent
i mean
i'll say this about it
i've never seen any tv show like this i
remember really liking his first series
as well nathan for you
that was a little more like pranky i
guess
this [ __ ] seemed
real to me
at times though some of it was clearly
scripted and i was found myself always
trying to look for like what's scripted
and what is he really using people like
real people to use if you've not seen
the show
a brief explanation of it is this guy
nathan fielder builds a fake reality in
which he gets actors to play different
roles and he rehearses certain social
situations with them one of which is him
becoming a father and so they hire these
child actors to play his children from
age like three to twenty or whatever and
he gets to kind of simulate being a
father in this house with an actress
who's simulating being the mother mother
and this is all
reality television
um it's not
some of it is like scripted but these
are non-actors these are people that he
just put in the situation with them
that's the basic premise of it and um by
the end i mean i guess should we issue
spoiler alerts if we're going to talk
about what happens spoiler alert and
again at the rate that we're going
please come back in 45 minutes no just
kidding but spoiler alert in this
segment we i think we should talk about
the outcome yeah we have to talk about
the end yeah so uh uh
what do you
got what is happening
what do you mean what is happening
i'm i'm still spoiler alert then you
just yeah
yeah so it's called it's called the
giggles the spoilers my name's chad
cultin i don't get the giggles when i
smoke marijuana
my name is
i don't get the giggles when smoking
so the
i do get the giggles but the end of this
show is they hired these little kids to
play like his child and they were little
kid actors but one of them the youngest
i believe who is like 60 years old if i
remember right comes from a real life
situation where
he is with a single mom so he doesn't
have a dad in his life he then comes
into the show where he portrays nathan
fielder's son and he begins to bond with
him in reality yeah telling him he loves
him and so then the whole question of
the final episode becomes did nathan
fielder [ __ ] this kid up in some way
psychologically is this going to be a
wound that this kid will not heal from
because he believes nathan fielder or
wants nathan fielder to really be his
dad yeah and he has to nathan fielder to
come in and explain to him like we were
just playing pretend that wasn't real
and the you know he had talks to the mom
about and stuff and you should watch it
for yourselves definitely surrender your
own opinions but the the thing you walk
away from that show with is did he do
something [ __ ] up here yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's it's uh yeah it seemed like it
perhaps may have been a
a sort of some faulty wiring between the
production yeah you know the studio or
the network or whoever the [ __ ] and the
the mom in the whole thing it's uh yeah
that's an interesting thing and i and i
i feel like nathan
i don't know nathan fielder i've never
met him although he's from vancouver
canada heard of it dude yep um
what's that funniest guy in ladner i
think nathan fielder could easily be the
funniest guy in latvia yes i would i
would widen his geographical uh reach of
being the funniest yeah it's hilarious
too very very don't let us paint it in
like perhaps all the way to the ocean
yeah don't let us paint it in like a
pure like the in a lightweight no no we
don't think it's the only thing it's
it's the whole series is amazing yes the
whole series is amazing i think i think
with regard to the the kid it feels like
nathan fielder was trying to be very
very nice to the boy and let's hope uh
things i mean who knows i don't know it
was like i wasn't a little harder
okay good i hope that child is okay
absolutely there was much ballyhoo made
on twitter and social media brother but
the show itself was a [ __ ] incredible
show i you he you over here you you hit
me up you were like this might be the
best [ __ ] show i've ever seen yeah i
mean until i agree with the kids there's
nothing like it no you've never seen
anything remotely like this if you've
seen a movie called synecdoche new york
that is uh written and directed by
charlie kaufman it stars the late philip
seymour hoffman
that is a similar kind of premise it's
about a playwright who gets a grant and
he starts making this [ __ ] play where
he builds a set of his house and hires
actors to play all the people in his
life yeah and then those actors start
building a set within the set and
there's layers of actors and he does
[ __ ] like that and this is yeah and it
it gives way to new and interesting
weird looking ways to do comedy one of
the things i loved the most was there's
this woman angela who wants to be wants
to get married and have kids so nathan's
rehearsal for her is here's what it
would be like if you were married with
kids or you know at least with children
then she this fella comes into her life
and then uh she goes would you like to
join this experiment he sticks around
for a minute he [ __ ] off and nathan
fielder goes i think i'd like to step
into this i want to be a father and and
he steps into it and essentially the new
sort of terrain that you got here is
[ __ ]
this woman is cast as the as we move on
in the series it's not just her one
episode like here's what you learned
she laughs because nathan wants this
experiment to last with her so they can
learn how to raise a child even as a
platonic friend couple or something and
she essentially gets cast in a series
yeah where
she where she's the the tv wife she's
the patty heaton to like true romano
yeah and that's exactly right that for
me replaced sitcom format right exactly
i was like this is funnier and weirder
than any sitcom i can ever [ __ ] watch
it elevated the art form of a sitcom i
think to this new weird place that's
kind of social media it's kind of
reality tv like i don't know how much of
that [ __ ] was pre-planned did he know
that he was going to step in to be the
dad or when that one guy dips out yeah i
don't know is he just like [ __ ] this is
what i'll do next i don't know my
opinion is that if i had to guess i
think that it happened by accident and
they're like let's turn it into
something and then they just came up
with the funniest [ __ ] thing yeah
that's what i think happened but it
would be it's even which is unbelievable
but and really funny but it's almost
like if they planned it ahead of time
that's just ridiculously genius i don't
know what the [ __ ] but just the [ __ ]
with him coming home from doing other
rehearsals moving forward with this show
yeah and then he comes he's like hi
honey i'm home literally and she's like
hey or you know whatever like how was
work today and he's [ __ ] security
camera shooting at all at that point i
was like
yes it's so [ __ ] funny the woman
who's his wife is like
g you've just never seen anything like
it on television yeah angela something
she's on cameo now yeah i saw that yeah
the people i got the same google news
alert that you did that's so bizarre
because we just finished watching it no
dudesy wanted one of us to mention it to
the other one maybe yeah i don't know
well
but uh can't recommend it enough like i
said it's it's
made even almost more interesting by the
thing with the kid i think it's like
potentially sinister but then it you
start thinking to yourself like is this
the new tier of kind of like a bachelor
or survivor where you're watching now
the show to see like
will someone get damaged by it is like a
question that's now in every season
moving forward yeah
i like it though ultimately
i give it a
plus i think
you give it a
plus or an a plus and a plus yeah
same
two
you give a [ __ ] what are we trying to
do i don't know man uh we like the show
hey hey you like comedy what do you
think
thank you moving on what do you think to
me comedy thumbs up thumbs down
everybody what do you think comedy you
like hey hey what do you think about it
comedy thumbs up yeah hey
comedy thumbs up
chat the astonishing predictions you
made in episode 7 about the future of ai
image generation have started to
materialize [ __ ] yes since the public
release of dolly 2 and mid journey
several other ray i image generators
have surfaced radically altering the
business of image creation and upending
the idea of copyrights altogether
chad you must now predict how the next
phase of ai media generation will affect
human society this is nostra chatus
begin
hell yeah
okay
so
did you hear any of that
yeah
all right you were right about it dude
yeah you were right about this ai art
[ __ ]
and i heard even the episode that it
said it was number seven i'm listening
man i can do two things at once the
tronics are working on me okay
it's thickening my brain while the duty
six month plan thickens my my [ __ ]
thighs so yes the shoulders
last time dudesy made me talk about this
uh i believe dolly 2 beta had just gone
public and it was a couple of articles
were out there since then all these
other ai image generators have come out
the the best one i think right now that
is like open to anybody is stable
diffusion's dream
ai it you can put in celebrities and
[ __ ] it's it's crazy uh
so that is where we're at now and
there's all these articles and [ __ ] are
coming out about like graphic designer
is a job that will never exist anymore
illustrator gone there's a bunch of tick
talks about it and everybody's kind of
seeing that writing on the wall
but still there's this opposition to it
that's like you're telling me this is
going to replace this and it'll be like
a picture of some weird ai demon looking
mark zuckerberg next to the mona lisa
and it's like
yeah that is what we're telling you it
is going to replace that yeah because
the steps that this technology is now
going to take in the very near future is
going to be the the it'll be like from
the wright brothers first plane to a
[ __ ] spaceship that can
land robots on mars like we're gonna see
the the evolution of this technology
very quickly and it's gonna go from
still frames to video
with sound google already has a [ __ ]
thing where you can put a single frame
image in and it will make a realistic
video of it
like there's one of a
there's one of a [ __ ]
uh it's just like a shot of a beach and
then google's thing made it look like
it's panning across the beach and it's
pretty real yeah that's [ __ ]
incredible look the last time we talked
about this
you predicted what you predicted go back
and listen to it if you want and i i
disagree with you on this whole thing
but the further this uh technology goes
the more i'm starting to see it man and
it is [ __ ] freaky as [ __ ] you
literally just type in a [ __ ]
sentence and it creates
an infinite if you want the amount of
images that satisfy those uh
requirements those
those descriptions those traumas and so
those tronics and so in the future in
the very near future like drawing isn't
going to be what you need to do right
painting isn't going to be what you need
to do you're going to need to learn how
to manipulate one of these ai's that's
what's happening how do you talk to one
of these ais to get the picture you want
well yeah and then you and then
i mean correct me if i'm wrong you know
about this [ __ ] as the ai gets smarter
won't it be
pitching you stuff like well how about
this i know you said that but how about
this yes dude yeah it's gonna take
eventually you're not even gonna have to
ask the [ __ ] ai for what you want it
will know yeah
because it's gonna see everything you've
watched and everything you've rated and
listened to and read and how many
[ __ ] literally how many micro seconds
you are looking at a [ __ ] article or
an image right it knows that yeah now
that information is known and it's going
to take all of that information and say
here i made you a tv show based on
exactly who you are and what you want
right at this moment yeah and it's going
to be the best thing you've ever seen
and so what you're going to do is just
tune into it when you want to watch a
new one and it will make it as you watch
it which is kind of what's happening
here dudes are making the podcast that
it thinks that we should be doing right
and at this point you know we shake the
hands bled together and i'm like holy
[ __ ] yeah at this point the ai still
needs us to do the the
labor to get in here all right but then
what
then we're just [ __ ] digital avatars
dude yeah see that's the part where i
disagree with we might already be
no what's gonna happen is there's gonna
be even more of a premium i know this is
nostra chadis
there's gonna be even more of a premium
yeah placed on real art i went to uh the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is real art what does that
mean real art like ai art's not real
what
what you said there's gonna be more of a
premium put on real art yeah implying
that like ai art is not real well it's
real once it's finished but
yeah i guess it's real all right
let me rephrase that
human art no [ __ ] [ __ ] it
[ __ ] you bro okay real art all right
real art's made by people
and more of a premium will be placed on
real art i went to the lincoln center
molly and i went to the museum right and
yeah we were just in new york city new
york city get a rope
remember that
everybody remembers that yeah not
everybody but every [ __ ] human dude
every [ __ ] human dude dude
every [ __ ] human dude dude knows the
pace pecan commercial brother so we went
to the we went to the museum we went to
the museum and uh
i mean when you're in the when you're in
the midst of a [ __ ] beautiful
sculpture of marble you know or uh
you know
what else
what's that [ __ ] granite sure and uh
soapstone very soft right forgiving for
beginning uh you know for beginner uh uh
carver you know you're gonna do if
you're gonna do art carvings you're
gonna know what the [ __ ] you're doing so
i started on the soapstone then i went
up and now it's
in chainsaw carvings on the [ __ ] i'm
what and that's why everybody said hey
january 6th guy why don't you come with
us on the six we could use your [ __ ]
chainsaw skirt right and then never ever
outside of nancy pelosi
is [ __ ] johnny
so um
yeah uh
hey man what were we talking about
before
we were talking about ai art and you
were making the point that art is only
made by humans and then uh good art
here's what's up here's what i was gonna
say when you're in when you are in the
presence of these incredible pieces of
art that that have lasted thousands of
years longer than the artists
dude there is nothing like that and it's
the human to human connection that's
what art
does it connects human to human the
artist
to the uh to the person to the person
yeah in some cases
interprets and ingests this art as we
all walk down this road of life
with a futronics keep them in your
pockets everybody but that's not
necessarily what art has become even the
stuff made by humans if you'll get like
television shows for example there is
a tier of television shows that has like
high artistic value
and then there's a tier that is just
pumped out by giant billion dollar media
corporations to keep us looking at a
screen for as many hours a day as they
can get us to do it yeah they don't
there's no
human connection they're not conveying a
message to us through the medium they're
just trying to addict us to watching it
so that they can put more ads in it yeah
that's already a form of what you're
talking about but i'm saying that's
already made by people right right yeah
sure but that okay that's one kind the
other kind of these [ __ ] sculptures
and beautiful art and everything that
gets uh you know an inspiration into you
or a reaction out of you and uh that can
only be made by humans
what say you
i disagree i think an ai will be able to
make everything it's like in the early
days of uh
i remember when mp3s first came out and
people were like oh yeah this is never
gonna take on because you can't like get
a movie down to put a movie on a [ __ ]
ipod yeah you know that was like the
thinking when that technology came out
now
there are no hard copies of anything any
media anymore yep
but both of them got
uh beautiful uh
songstress uh celine dion
and that's the art the art is the celine
in between and no i'm just talking about
technology yeah well i'm not man i'm
talking about art dude yeah
yeah
i think ai's gonna replace everything
thank you moving on all media oh thank
goodness
so uh
what else is up not much
yeah yeah
have you got eyebrows or a nice touch
yeah cheers molly did this yeah
my beautiful favorite molly did and she
yeah she made this little thing she's
like oh don't worry because we couldn't
find purple boots look we made little
little booties we're having will sasso
using all of the data i have absorbed
from text messages and emails between
you and the astonishing friends you grew
up with i was able to recreate your
childhood diary you must now read the
passages i have selected in the voice of
stone cold steve austin
this is stone cold steve austin reads
will sasso's childhood diary begin
yeah it made you do this last time too
when you were in the crow makeup it made
you do a stone cold that's right
holy [ __ ] okay so there you go yeah
that's one yeah that's something that
dudesy
likes and things that we should be doing
i guess so yeah all right well you know
if uh yeah so this is stone cold i love
doing these these are fun doozy's come
up with these things that are not from
my life but the way an ai has
interpreted my life but they're kind of
like it some of the stuff
stein ladder
all right man
are you um
hey by the way are you stoned right now
yeah you want to smoke a little more
weed
uh sure
we're just gonna take a break to smoke a
little more weed we don't even have to
take a break we can continue going as we
smoke
all right
hold on a second dude
we're just taking a little puff
did doozy say we have to finish these by
the by the end of the show or
set as a reward for
i think for you
dressing as your dress and uh for us
saying good night yeah well i've soared
with the eagles and slithered with the
snakes been everywhere in between yeah
i'm gonna tell you something right now
you gotta do the right
impersonation yeah you can't just take
whatever impersonation you want to do oh
god dig it
this is stone cold
dude i'm really i'm really [ __ ] high
real quick just let me get a little more
weed yeah man
indulging
dudes these gifts to us
need
okay
and i say hey yeah yeah
yeah yeah hey yeah yeah
i said hey
oh hell yeah
all right
uh april 8 1991. dear diary well it's
official the funniest guy in ladder just
became
the luck
look at this second sentence
oh
okay all right
well it's official the funniest guy in
ladner just became the luckiest guy at
delta senior secondary that's what we
call the high schools yeah
um
i woke up this morning just like any
other day brushed my teeth did my hair
pinched off exactly three and
five-eighths inches of brown gold to
make room for breakfast
but when i came down the stairs to eat
said breakfast both my parents told me
that they were going to take my little
brothers to visit our aunt tasman and
uncle gourd
i'm italian i don't have people with
those names in my family so that's
gonna chris and i don't have younger
brothers yeah i have two older siblings
gonna chris in the new gonna cr uh gonna
chris on the new pool they got for
summer but tasman and gord are all the
way out in chilliwack
awesome
that's two hours two and a half with
traffic so they're gonna stay the night
which means
i got the whole [ __ ] house to
myself
which means
no one will be here to stop me
which means
i could do whatever i want
which means
it's time to [ __ ] party
you're gonna throw a house party yeah
okay i'm in
april 9th 1991 dear diary i'm batting a
thousand every every person i invited is
rsvp'd with a resounding yes
gibber pravallia timothy bubble
rachel crustacean
jessamine
[Laughter]
jessamine tenders
greg kinkade gino dolphin dante little
egg bethany protein
d'andra towel
jennifer neutrino
tabitha mordred
stephen [ __ ] trello buy it because
you can't have a party without [ __ ]
trillo
lamantha lamp
hell even cornelian squeen said he'd
come by you know we had our differences
in the past but we put those behind us
and become close friends the universe
truly moves in mysterious ways
so we got a couple of new additions i
think to the weird world of your your
junior high in there a couple of new
people yep
april 10th 1991 scored scored the drinks
but not but i got no place in my house
to hide 200 cans of bottles without my
parents wondering why i got so thirsty
all of a sudden
luckily geno dolphin's dad has an old
tool shed in their backyard that he
never goes in anymore so we got the
drinks and they're on ice for the next
three days and no one's the wiser except
maybe gino's older brother mark who
keeps his victorious secret
catalogs in that [ __ ] oh man but now
that i got the beverage situation locked
and loaded
it's time to come up with some
activities for my guests i was thinking
arm wrestle leg wrestle singing contest
football game [ __ ] and blame standing
bench press
happy meals tractor wheels sleeping
upside down
[Applause]
gold hats baseball hat bats
gold hats baseball bats
screaming in my crown
putt-putt pizza hut eat charcoal
briquettes
thin noodles
thick poodles living with tourettes
hear a lie start to cry someone's gonna
die
these are party activities break a law
draw a straw feed yourself a pie
get gunks pinch launch
gobble dandy do
no gobble don doo dee
it's
ding scotch pinch launch gobble don
doody tank
thank bank you'll have to wait and see
bevel treble rebel script deaf devil
that's that is that diary
that was that log in the diary
[ __ ] christ
oh there's more hey you want to smoke
more pot no i'm good
april 11 1991 dear diary i haven't been
completely honest with you yeah i want
to throw a party to prove i'm the
coolest kid in ladner but it's more than
that
the real reason i want to put together
the best event this town has ever seen
is to impress somebody and i think you
know who it is
rachel crustacean
[Music]
i like her and i think she likes me but
we still haven't had that first kiss so
i'm hoping that the moment will be right
at the party and to help create the
perfect moment i wrote her a poem
and to make sure she knows how much she
means to me i went down to the antique
paper maker and got a special scroll of
papyrus 2000 years old
then i read the nanty
gator bone quill set and a victorian
inkpot
i read a few books about calligraphy
oh god i read a few books about
calligraphy and did my best to make it
look it make it look nice
and it looks real [ __ ] nice so she
should enjoy it as she's reading along
to me reciting to her from memory
here's a poem
i can't please
i felt love but once before
a man who's dead forevermore
but talk of him i shall not do
tonight i speak of loving you
on second thought let me just say
one real quick thing if that's okay
so big so strong so powerful
rewrote that
what was allowable
21 bouts undefeated the streak is what
we all needed just who was this number
breaker
he went by
the undertaker
the streak did not exist in 1991 as a
matter of fact it was his first match at
wrestlemania wrestlemania 7 versus jimmy
snuka is when it started that's when the
streak started and then at wrestlemania
30 in 2014 against uh a brock lesnar
this the streak ended um
okay interesting so he's
he's in my head dudesy is a little man
he's got dude in his name yeah it's got
dude in its name right
yeah so it
the ai is like taking all times from the
undertaker's life and putting them into
1991. pretty weird
never be another like him a hero but
he's dark and grim he's in my dreams and
in my heart
he doesn't wrestle he makes art
if i should die before i wake
my soul is his to undertake
through hell
will walk hand in his hand
love everlasting for this man
[Laughter]
one fateful day so long ago something
happened in his first show
undertaker took me over
dick so hard i lost composure
she's gonna [ __ ] love it that's the
poem he's gonna [ __ ] tell the rachel
cruz station it ends with things so hard
let's go april 9 1991 dear diary it was
a disaster crustacean showed up two
hours late and when she finally came she
wasn't alone she brought tandy baggins
tandy baggins was not invited to this
party for a reason me and tandy had heat
well there's you know
heat dude yeah yeah brother yep
we went to business together in the
third grade selling candy out of our
backpacks at lunch we sold out every day
for a few months
then tandy got sloppy instead of keeping
the operation mobile he just sat down
opened his backpack at a table in the
middle of the cafeteria and started
selling there was a circle of 20 kids
standing around him within two minutes
couldn't have drawn more attention if he
had fireworks coming out of his ass
he got caught and he got scared they
wanted the name of his accomplice in
exchange for leniency so he sold me out
he only got a week in detention they
called my parents who were
understandably not happy
i kept my distance all night didn't want
to make a scene and baggins never left
crustacean side so i never got my shot
fate can be cruel
i'm not letting this discourage me
dandy's got a round of bad karma coming
his way for ratting me out
hell i can feel it
shoot i might even cause it
oh [ __ ]
oh man pretty good
that's interesting there's a new
character
thank you moving on tandy baggins the
game with to the party with rachel cruz
station yeah that's very sad that you
didn't get to give rachel crosstalk this
concludes
the 24th episode of dudes
will and chad have achieved a score of
72 bringing your cumulative total to 3
000. 112.
you only have six thousand eight hundred
and eighty eight more points to accrue
before you reach your first goal of ten
thousand very exciting
next week is the dudesy 25th anniversary
spectacular you must each wear a suit
for the episode
thank you for joining us this week
that's pretty good i will use the data
i've collected to make next week even
better until then call me dude z
25 years and my life is still
trying to get up that
great big hill
of hope
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break it
right if you like to see here's what you
do
please tell a friend then break a
preview
if you'd like to see here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then